hi I'm Sal Khan founder of the Khan
Academy and I just wanted to let you
know how excited all of us are for what
we have in stores is coming back to
school first and foremost this is going
to be a big effort in terms of working
with teachers and classrooms this coming
back to school teachers are going to be
able to better assign practice on Khan
Academy and get reports on where their
students are to give optimal
personalized practice this practice is
going to be aligned with standards
across subjects and grades we're also
adding a lot more content and to be
clear Khan Academy is much much much
more than just videos we have standards
aligned practice across subjects and
grades people look out for well beyond
math biology chemistry physics and
especially this coming year we're adding
a lot in history we're creating many
tools for independent learners and folks
who are trying to prepare for college
and important standardized exams like
the SAT we're really trying to reach the
world our mission is a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere so we're
going to continue our efforts in Spanish
and Portuguese in Sindhi and launch and
other significant geographies so there's
a lot of work ahead of us but we're very
very very excited and I just want to
thank all of y'all for being part of the
Khan Academy community and many of you
have directly supported these efforts
and I hope you to feel proud of all of
the reach and impact that we are able to
collectively have